- [Joe] One thing that-
- [Gary] You want a seat?
You want us to get you a seat, you sure?
We got it right there if you want it.
- [Jimmy] Of course!
Thank you.
Thanks.
(Joe groans)
- [Joe] You ever see
John, the way he walked?
He used to bop along, with
a little bounce in his step,
and he had that big behind.
- [Gary] Huge behind.
- The brother's on the team
named "Chocolate Chip".
(both laugh)
- Makes sense.
- That never made it out
- Of radio or anything,
- It was an inside thing.
- The brother, you had "Chocolate Chip,
"You got have a little black in you, man."
- A little something.
- [Joe] "Chocolate Chip."
(crew laughs)
- And the afro, he was set.
- [Joe] (laughs) He had
the afro, that's right,
- He was set.
- To go along with
the double-booty, the big booty.
- He was set.
(crew chatters off-mic)
Anything you wanna talk about, Joe?
- [Joe] Anything you want to talk about
- You got it.
- Is fine.
- You're set to go.
- We're good to go?
What are we going live on?
- [Engineer] Facebook and YouTube.
- And the IG right there?
And are you live or not yet?
Any second?
And you're good?
- [Joe] Do I need to touch this at all?
- Nah, you're in great shape.
(crew chatters off-mic)
What episode is it?
- [Engineer] 311.
- 311.
Hey everybody, it's Gary Vaynerchuck,
and this is episode 311
of the Ask Gary Vee show,
and one that I will watch
in perpetuity forever,
easily one of the most
important men in my life,
without him fully knowing it,
to every single code that
I ever had on my ATM,
on my passwords, several years
ago when I started realizing
more people knew who I was,
I had to go and change everything
from January 12th, 1969,
'cause I felt that people
would eventually figure out
that those were all my passwords.
- [Joe] (laughs) That's great.
- Joe, it's a real honor to have you here.
Obviously, my fanbase knows literally,
what you probably don't know
is I emigrated to this country
from the Soviet Union,
originally lived in Queens,
and I moved to Edison, New Jersey,
and the real way I got Americanized
was absolutely New York Jets football.
My first season, back to John Riggins,
we were talking before we started this,
was the '82 season, which
was a great one for the Jets,
and, obviously, had they beaten Miami,
they would've played John
Riggins skins in that game,
and literally from that day on,
it has become the core thing in my life
is the New York Jets, besides my family,
so you can imagine how much
fun it is to have you here,
so thanks for being on.
- Well thank you, thanks for having me.
- So I have a lot of things
I want to talk to you about,
and the format of the show
is we're gonna do calls,
obviously, I've been promoting on social,
so a bunch of people are gonna
be super excited to call in,
I'm gonna start with a
couple of different things.
I think, you know, the one
luxury of actually being
a hardcore Jets fan is that
I think I can take these
in different directions
than the normal stuff,
so actually, what I wanna talk about
is the season after the Super Bowl.
A game that kind of still sits,
obviously this happened,
I was born in '75,
but the game against the Chiefs
that we lost in the
playoffs the next year,
I guess my first question would be,
was the team after the
Super Bowl a better team
than the Super Bowl team?
And obviously "better" is a funny word,
but did you think we were
gonna win Super Bowl IV?
- I didn't necessarily think
we were gonna win Super Bowl IV,
but we felt like we were playing well,
and we ended up playing a team
that outplayed us that day,
the Kansas City Chiefs, man,
and you bring it up, Gary,
it was a windy, cold, funky day in Shea-
- [Gary] In Shea, yeah, we were home.
- We were home,
and we got held to six points, all right?
- [Gary] I'm aware.
- Bobby Bell, they had four or five
defensive players in the
Hall of Fame now, you know,
I mean, they were good,
and I remember a play that,
I actually thought about
trying to fool Bobby Bell,
during the week when
we were getting ready,
and I made a big mistake.
You don't fool Bobby Bell, you know,
a great linebacker that he was,
and we only scored six
points, they beat us, man.
- When I bring up that game, right,
what are the biggest things
that you think about?
Did that game stick with you?
Because obviously, and some of
this stuff I might get wrong,
because obviously I wasn't around,
but the next season, you got hurt, right?
Because next season was
a 4-11 season, right?
- Yeah.
- And it was like,
I don't know you well
enough to know, you know,
is it stuff you think about?
Is it not?
But that season, for some reason,
I don't know why it sticks, obviously,
everybody talks about the prior season,
and Len Dawson.
What kind of player was Len Dawson?
- Lenny Dawson was sweet, man.
I mean, he was sweet, he was smooth.
I tried to run like Lenny Dawson.
- (laughs) The knees
- I'm talking about
- Wouldn't let you.
- Jogging, on and off
- He was a good ball player.
- the field, you know.
- I was impressed with his
mannerisms, his coolness,
he was a real gentleman,
and he was brilliant as a player.
- But that game, that season,
did that hurt for a long time?
You had so much going on
in your life at that point,
obviously, the prior season
puts you on a pedestal,
in this city, the biggest
city in the world,
are you the kind of guy
that after that game,
you're devastated for 24 hours?
You think about it for a month?
Or you go down to Miami and have fun?
What kind of guy were you?
I'm very curious what happens
after that level of adversity,
I assume we're at home,
the Raiders were a really
good team that year too,
so you have to face those
guys again if you win,
but were you upset?
Or were you kind of like,
you understood that they outplayed you,
I'm trying to get into the mindset of
you're walking off the field,
and then what happens the next 30 days.
- Gary, I'll share with you
what my head coach
told my freshman class
of football players at
the University of Alabama
the first time we met our head coach
and had a meeting with him,
Coach Paul "Bear" Bryant.
He stood up in front of us and he said
"I'm gonna teach y'all how to
keep from beating yourselves."
Now, I came from PA, man,
it's tough for me to understand him,
(Gary laughs)
and we won a championship
back there in Beaver Falls,
and that sounded to me like, what,
playing conservative or playing scared?
"I'm gonna teach y'all how to
keep from beating yourselves."
And then he said "You're
gonna remember the losses.
"The mistakes.
"The games you didn't play well in
"more than you're gonna
remember the good games,
"even the big games you've won."
To this day, you bring up
the Kansas City Chiefs game
in 1969,
I promise you,
that's one of the ones
we're talking about,
- Stacked state.
- Coming from Coach Bryant.
Losing to Texas my senior
year in the Orange Bowl,
that jumps up at me.
Losing once to that team
from across Alabama State,
A-Burn, I called them, for most folks
(Gary laughs)
but losing to them,
that gets me right here to this day.
Sure, we won the championship, man,
and I mentioned high school, college,
the goal for every player should
be to make the team own up,
you gotta be good enough
to get on any team,
whether it's little league baseball,
junior high basketball,
you gotta make the team,
and the next goal should
be to win the championship.
- [Gary] That's right.
- And we did it on those levels,
and I'm thrilled about that,
but I think of the games I played
like a bum first.
- Do you think you played
like a bum in that game?
- In which game?
The Kansas City Chiefs game?
- I know there's four picks in that game,
but, you know, real football fans know
some of those are on the quarterback,
and some of them are not.
- And some are on a good defensive play-
- Or somebody running
- And they can make excuses
- A wrong round
- about the hawk,
- Or something silly, sure.
- All that stuff,
- Missed a hawk
- They're talking about
the hawk, the wind, you know.
But no, I mean, I didn't play well.
Had I played well, we would've
possibly won the game.
You know what?
That triggers a thought
when I think about it,
Tom Brady.
I think about Tom Brady
in this day and age,
and after watching him over the years,
I know I literally lost a game
or more when I played for the Jets.
I haven't seen Tom Bray in 18 years,
or since he's been
playing for the Patriots,
cost them a game.
- Well, you know, it's funny,
because the playoff game
that we went up there
and beat them on,
I thought the pass that he threw
that David Harris intercepted
changed the complete
complexity of that game
throughout the rest of the game,
so I'll chalk that up to Tom Brady's loss.
- Okay, that's one play.
- I'll take it, I'll take it though.
(Joe laughs)
I want it.
Listen, I'm hanging on here, Joe.
- Okay, that's right.
- As a diehard Jets fan,
that name is tough to deal
with, as you can imagine.
Let me ask you another question
that I was really curious about.
By the way, everybody who's watching,
you put in calls, I'm gonna talk to Joe
a lot about marketing, because
I think what Sonny did,
and we'll get into this,
I'm very curious from your
perspective of being the human.
There is no question in my mind,
my brother A.J. and I started
this marketing company,
and several years ago, he
left to follow his passion,
and my brother is in the football
sports representation business,
so he's a football agent,
and obviously we come from
a marketing background,
so you can imagine I'm very affected
with the way you became who
you were in the public eye,
and that wasn't just who you were
as a charismatic, successful player,
it was the people around you
that were helping you make decisions
on brand deals, the SI cover is all-time,
the pantyhose thing is all-time,
there's a lot of things that were done
between you and your team
that has created the
legendary status that you are,
obviously the game is so
disproportionately powerful,
but I don't think people understand
how a full thing is usually built,
so for everybody who's watching,
because I know marketing
and entrepreneurship
is such a big part of me and this show,
we'll get to that,
you're gonna have to stick with me,
because I'm going very nerd football here,
because I've gotta see
it through for myself,
I'm very curious,
and I actually don't have as
much knowledge about this,
because this is the period where
I don't know as much about,
Richard Todd.
This is very interesting to me,
because the '82 season is my first season,
and he was the Jets
quarterback at that time,
so he was my first Jets quarterback,
when I look at the history
books and read stuff,
he comes into the team with all this fame
and things of that nature,
there's a story I can't
recall about something,
you said some amazing joke to him
at a training camp or something,
I don't remember the whole story,
and I might even be getting it wrong,
I'm curious, as a nerdy, nerdy Jets fan,
where were you at the
point in your career,
what was your relationship like with him,
when I say that name, give
me a story or two that
maybe you haven't told, or
give me a scoop here, Joe,
tell me something about
you and Richard Todd.
- Every year that I played pro football,
the 13 years that I played,
I would go back to
Tuscaloosa, Alabama, man.
- Every year.
- To train,
- I didn't know that.
- That's right,
that's where I'd go do
my training, I'd go back-
- Joe, I'm going to interrupt
you, and I apologize,
and everyone's laughing now
because I love to do it,
as a PA boy,
obviously I've seen you
talk about it a lot,
coach down there and that scene,
that was really transformational for you,
that time down there, huh?
- It was, I didn't even visit the campus
before I went there.
I didn't know Coach Paul
"Bear" Bryant at the time.
I saw Alabama play one
game before I went there,
and that was in the Liberty Bowl
on a black-and-white television,
and I really didn't
know anything about it.
- Who came in second for Joe Namath?
- Second where?
- If you didn't go to 'Bama,
where would've you gone?
- Maryland, University
of Maryland had I passed
the college boards, but I
didn't score high enough
- You flat-out wanted
- On the college boards-
- to go to Maryland.
- No, I didn't want to go to college,
(laughs)
I wanted to play baseball.
- [Gary] Is that true?
- I had the opportunity to
sign a baseball contract,
but at home, that was at
a time where you still did
what your mother, your father said,
and my father and mother
had divorced early on,
not so early, but it was early in my life,
and now it was time to decide
what the youngest in the
family was going to do,
go to college or sign
the baseball contract,
and so we had a meeting at the house.
My oldest brother ran the meeting,
my mother was sitting
there, and brother Bob said,
"Well, mom," he turned to her, he said
"Mom, what do you want Joe to do?"
And my mother said "Oh,
"I want Joey to go to college."
(Gary laughs)
Bob hit the table-
(pounds table)
"That's it,
"you're going to college."
- That was it.
- That was it!
- [Gary] And were you pissed?
- I was crushed.
(Gary laughs)
I couldn't be too angry
because Bob could still
beat me up then, you know-
- But were you really disappointed?
- Man, I had a brand new
Starfire Pontiac Convertible
(Gary laughs)
picked out, man,
powder blue with a chrome
strip along the side,
a white top,
50,000 dollar bonus in 1961-
- Which is like
= Which is pretty cool.
- A trillion dollars.
- Yeah man,
are you kidding?
I loved the baseball.
I'd run around and catch and
bat like Roberto Clemente,
or tried to, you know,
I really loved baseball, but-
- [Gary] Mom wanted you to go to college.
- That was that.
(stammers)
- And then Maryland hit your radar-
- Maryland-
- Why?
- I liked Tom Nugent, the coach there,
I liked his style of
football, they threw it a lot,
he started the I-formation
when he was at Florida State,
and he was just a charismatic guy.
- And Joe, this was not an
era where a big prospect
like Joe Namath with
not passing the boards,
like Maryland couldn't
figure out some funny,
that wasn't the ecosystem in
college football back then?
- It didn't work that way,
and what happened is Coach
Nugent called Coach Bryant-
- Interesting, interesting.
- And let him know that
I was still loose.
And unbeknownst to me, I didn't
know Howard Schnellenberger,
an Assistant Coach at
Alabama at that time,
showed up at our house in Beaver Falls,
there was a knock at the door,
and he came in and talked to my mother.
- And that was that.
- She went upstairs,
packed me a suitcase you
could put under the front seat
of this, you know, a bus
seat, now on a plane,
it was that big, came downstairs,
gave me a five dollar bill,
and looked at Coach
Schnellenberger and said
"Take him."
And that was it, man, I was
off to Tuscaloosa, Alabama,
I never heard of Tuscaloosa, Alabama
(Gary laughs)
before that.
- [Gary] What about
Alabama itself? (laughs)
- Well I did see them
play in the Liberty Bowl,
I liked their style, man,
they had dark headgears and
white uniforms that day,
- That would work for you.
- I remember,
and I caught myself pulling
for them, but they lost.
- And so, back to the story,
so you go down, and Todd is down there,
one of those off-seasons.
- Well, you see, I was, again,
already playing pro ball,
but I'd go back to train,
May, June, early June,
before our training camp,
and Richard was the quarterback at Alabama
one of those years, and they
were running a wishbone offense
when he was a senior.
But when he was younger player,
before they put the wishbone in,
Richard was still running
sprint-out stuff and throwing.
So I used to work with Richard
specifically on dropping back,
the straight drop-back
pass, he had a strong arm,
and he was good,
he was a big heart, good teammate, man,
you'd like everything about Richard,
except that day against Miami, maybe,
down there in the bad weather with
- [Both] A.J. Dewey.
(laughs)
- That one hurts.
- I know.
- That's the first time I cried.
Only the '86
Browns loss
made me cry harder,
but that was a tough one.
- Yeah, well, you know,
some are tougher than others,
- Yep, yep.
- They all stink, you know,
you never get tired of winning,
two things in life we don't
get tired of, staying healthy,
- [Both] And winning.
- [Gary] For sure.
- You know, your girlfriend
will run you off,
or you'll wanna run her off sometimes.
- [Gary] For sure, winning and health.
- The two things that are steady
are good health and winning.
- So did you tell the Jets
that you thought that,
was there ever a conversation
between you and the
front office about Todd?
- There might've been, because
we drafted him number one
in '76, we drafted Richard number one.
And Richard had great
training with Coach Bryant,
I mean he was a fine
player and strong, but-
- How much pressure
was on him in New York?
Because he came from 'Bama,
he also had good hair,
his was blonde, was
there a lot of pressure
and expectation on him to live up?
- I would think more than I could realize-
- [Gary] Did you talk to him about it?
- Not about that, no,
- That's how we did.
Hey, no, man, we were buddies,
- Talked about going out
- We were like
- And hanging, yeah.
- New Richard, yeah.
We went to dinner, we hung out,
we were together, man.
And no, I didn't ask
him about the pressure,
didn't wanna make anything about it, yeah,
"You gonna follow in my footsteps?"
- None of that.
- No, man,
it wasn't that kind of thing.
- Joe, I have another
question, back to nerddom,
what's the biggest thing you learned
from when you went to L.A.?
(stammers)
At least from what I can see,
it wasn't a great success with the Rams-
- No.
- But forget about
what happened on the
football field for a sec,
or maybe something you
learned on the football field,
I don't know, if I ask you what
was the single biggest thing
you learned
with the Rams experience,
what was it?
- To get something positive
out of a negative season,
which happened to be the
teammates that I did play with,
Jack Youngblood, Tom Mack, you know,
these kind of cats, Lawrence
McCutcheon, Jackson,
the friendships that I
developed with the players,
the coach, Chuck Knox there at the time,
Chuck was our offensive
line coach with the Jets
my rookie season and second season.
- [Gary] So you had a relationship there.
- Yeah, but
I couldn't play as well,
I had two severed
hamstrings in my left leg
that I played my last five
years or so years with,
and you can't run with
a severed hamstring,
but you can still play
quarterback to some extent.
- When you watch the watch
the current state of the rules
for quarterbacks in the NFL,
do you once in a while,
it's kind of the classic thing
that everybody does, right,
to like a son or a daughter,
like "In my day, I walked-",
there has to be, when these
phantom 15-yard penalties,
where the guy sneezes on the quarterback,
meanwhile the Raiders are
literally double piledriving you
to the concrete in these games,
at some level, once in
a blue moon on a Sunday
in the last five years,
you've gotta be like
"Geez, what I could've done
"if this was the rules when I played."
- No.
- Never.
- No, Gary, I tell you what-
- You don't allow yourself to do that.
- Well, I don't, I was
trained that way, in a sense.
Coulda, woulda, shoulda-
- Doesn't matter.
- Excuse me,
and no "Yeah, but"'s, too. (laughs)
- So forget about you as a human,
do you just laugh about-
- [Joe] No, I'm gonna tell you something.
- Please, I'm listening.
- The first year I did color,
I did with NBC, I made the statement
I said "I don't care if
Hulk Hogan is back there
(Gary laughs)
"in the pocket,
"he's gonna get hurt."
They needed to change the rules.
- I got it.
- They needed,
because if you knock the best guy out,
the quality of the game is going downhill,
and the fans are losing out.
They're not getting the
best possible performance.
You had to protect the quarterbacks some,
because hey, the backups are backups-
- [Both] For a reason,
- Yeah, and you keep going down, man,
it's the quality of game that suffers.
- St. Louis drafted you,
along with the Jets,
two separate leagues, how
close were you not a Jet?
Like how much of a shot did
St. Louis actually have?
- You know what-
- For real, for real.
- For real, for real,
- I'm like, this is one
- I promise you.
- That I really wanna know.
- This is all for real,
I promise you that.
The St. Louis Cardinals
showed up unannounced
in Tuscaloosa, Alabama,
in my dorm's lobby.
I'm up in my room-
- Doing what? (laughs)
- It's daytime.
- With you, bro, I don't know.
(laughs)
I'm up in my room,
a knock, "Hey, Namith,
there's a couple of guys
"to see you."
I didn't even know who drafted me,
it wasn't like today-
- I know, I know.
- We didn't know,
it wasn't televised,
it wasn't phone calls,
you know, I mean, these
two guys came upstairs,
one was the general manager
and one was one of the owners,
and they sat down on my bed
'cause I wouldn't let them sit
on my roommate's bed over there,
(Gary laughs)
my room with Pelham, Butch Henry,
was named after General Pelham,
the southerner, you know, the Confederacy,
anyway, we sat on the bunks,
and the owner guy told
me they had drafted me,
and wanted to sign me to a contract,
and I said "Oh well, good,
"but I haven't heard
from the other team yet,"
he said "Well that's all right,
"you're not gonna have to listen to them,
"we're gonna sign you,
"and we're gonna offer you-"
Well, no, it wasn't
"We're gonna offer you",
they asked me what I wanted to play,
and Coach Bryant had asked
me that same question
after the Auburn game, our last
game of the regular season,
and I told Coach Bryant
in the locker room,
as I was down on my knee putting the sock
on our backup quarterback
Steve Sloan's leg,
'cause he was hurt, too,
and I said "Well, coach,
"Don Trull signed for 100,000 last year,"
I said "I was thinking of 100,000,"
looking up at Coach Bryant.
Coach Bryant took a draw
off that big ol' Chesterfield
cigarette he was doing there,
and he (blows) blew some smoke,
and he said "Well,
"you go ahead and ask them for 200,000,"
he said, "That's the
better place to start."
(laughs)
- That's amazing.
- So these guys, he said
"Well, what do you think
you're gonna want here?",
I told him, I could hardly
get it out, you know-
- 200,000.
- 200,00 dollars.
And the guy fell back,
"Oh, 200,000!"
The other guy starts,
"200,000, you crazy?"
and I remembered,
"Oh, and the new car, too."
(Gary laughs)
"Oh, you want a new car too, do you?
"You want a new car?"
And I said "Well, yes, sir."
- You skipped baseball,
you gotta get that baseball
car back, I get it. (laughs)
- He asked me what kind of car,
'cause I talked an old
high school team roommate
maybe a few days before,
and he asked me what I was gonna ask for,
and I told him about Coach Bryant,
and asking me that money,
and he said, "Well man, what
kind of Short you gonna get?"
I said "Well, I don't know,
I didn't think about that."
He said "Oh, you need to get you a
"Lincoln Continental convertible."
(Gary laughs)
He said
"It's got them barn doors,
"those doors that open
out this way," you know,
and so
I told
the owner and the general manager,
I said "A Lincoln Continental."
They looked at each other and said,
(mockingly) "Oh, sure!
"He wants a Lincoln Continental!"
Made me feel like a real jerk.
- And so how did it end?
Did they say "Thank
you" and kind of leave?
- No, it didn't end there,
the man went in his briefcase
and pulled out a contract.
Pulled out a contract.
And he said "Now look, okay, all right,"
and he's got this contract,
he's gonna pass it,
"No, no, no, no, wait a minute.
"We got a ball game yet."
Coach Bryant had told myself
and the other guys, certainly,
- Can't sign it
- That were seniors.
- [Gary] Until your course.
- Yeah, we had a ball game
coming up, January first!
So they tried to get
me to sign right then.
- Of course.
- They knew the rules.
But, you know, that's okay,
I just had to tell them no,
I can't do that now, we've
got a game coming up.
Coach Bryant actually told us
that if we were being recruited,
"Don't you even take a Coca-Cola from 'em.
"Any of these guys,", that's right,
'cause we had a game coming up.
- So you got them out of the room somehow
without signing the deal.
- Yes, that's right.
And I sat there alone,
wondering "Wow,
"what do I do now?"
So I called a buddy,
a student, a regular student,
he was a dealer in Las Vegas
(Gary laughs)
in between semesters,
Hugh B., and he came over, picked me up,
we drove down to a restaurant
called The Deep South
for a cup of coffee to talk this over.
- That's cool.
- And as he and I
are talking, I said "Damn,
I gotta get some help."
So I got up and went to the pay phone,
at the time it was a
dime for the pay phone,
and I called a buddy up in
Alabama who was a lawyer,
Mr. Michael "Hike'll" Bite,
and told him the situation,
and so then I had legal representation,
and Mike handed it the rest of the way
for that initial contract.
- [Gary] And the Jets won.
- Well, the Jets won, they
flew me and Mike, actually,
Mike paid for the plane
fare to fly to Los Angeles,
and I met Mr. Werblin in Beverly Hills,
at the Beverly Hills
Hotel, trees and sunny.
- That was a smart move by Sonny, uh-huh.
- Unbelievable.
And it was spectacular.
And he wanted to sign with the Jets,
and we were able to go to a game
and watch the Jets and
the San Diego chargers
play down in San Diego.
We drove down there, and
then I went back to Alabama,
and we met again with Mr. Werblin,
well, he was the man
doing everything then.
- Yeah, he was.
There was a big partnership,
but he was running it.
- Yeah, yes, that's right,
and had Weeb Eubank
being the general manager
who knew something about
football, you know,
the other owners were in
thoroughbred industry,
the oil industry, you
know, the fashion industry,
they were different, and
it's just the kind of guy Mr. Werblin was,
was an influence, and that's the thing,
Coach Bryant told me
"Get to know the people
"you're gonna work for."
- [Gary] 100 percent.
- And that was so important
because it became a no contest,
after the two guys.
- How quickly did your
relationship with Sunny
turn into him saying,
did he communicate to you that "Hey, kid,
"I'm gonna make you a superstar?"
His blueprint on treating you
like he treated other
celebrities from L.A.
was not a model that was in
sports up until that point.
I mean that Broadway Joe thing
is real, real, real stuff.
I don't think people
understand in this day and age
what Sports Illustrated
meant, what that cover meant,
every single young guy in the country
sees that magazine cover,
and that positions you right away.
Did you know that that was going on,
or was he just kind of doing it,
or was that something you were a part of.
- Gary, you're right on.
You're right on.
It was Mr. Werblin.
At one point, I overheard
him telling someone else,
whether it was he and
his wife and I, together,
or whoever,
"Stars sell tickets."
He created the star system,
- He sure did.
- So to speak,
in professional football.
- He did.
- We had Red Grange
many years ago, Jim Brown
was a star, you know,
- [Gary] There were
Yankees that were stars.
- Catered to in a sense,
they weren't built up,
we weren't built up.
- And you crossed over.
- He embraced the media in New York.
He started inviting the media into areas
and buying them lunch
and visiting with them.
He reached out to the media,
and he got it off the ground, man,
I mean it wouldn't surprised me
if he called Sports Illustrated himself
to get that picture on Broadway.
Yeah, he was instrumental
not only in my career,
but in the AFL's existence.
- How did it feel the
first time you saw yourself
on the cover of Sports
Illustrated like that?
- I was stunned.
(Gary laughs)
First time I saw it, we
were practicing at Shea,
I came in off the practice
field, and on my stool,
and every other player's
stool around the locker room,
was that magazine, the Sports Illustrated,
with my smiling face looking up.
I had a few veterans pick
up the magazine, look at it,
and then throw it at me, you know,
I'm ducking magazines,
you know, embarrassed,
actually,
it was kind of scary,
some of them were cursing
a little bit about it,
and I'm sitting here straight across,
like where you're sitting over there,
straight across from me,
the offensive linemen are sitting there,
and our offensive
leader, Sherman Plunkett,
offensive tackle, who was about 6'5",
and we didn't know how much he weighed,
(Gary laughs)
because the scales only went
up to 300 then, you see.
And I used to carry Sherman's helmet
off the practice field, from
training camp to that day,
he would leave his helmet there
and I would carry it off for him, right,
and I'm sitting there and
I look across over there
and there's Sherman,
looking at the magazine.
(Gary laughs)
And I'm looking at Sherman,
and then Sherman picks his head up,
and he looks over at me,
he smiles, and just the
words came out his mouth,
"Ol' Broadway!
"Broadway Joe!"
And then from that time on,
it was cool, it was nice.
- He cosigned it, he
allowed the rest of the team
- Well, for him to say that,
- To embrace it.
- Yeah, that caught on,
that was cool, yeah.
- Really interesting.
It's super interesting
for me to look from afar
at somebody who thinks about
attention and marketing,
that whole process, jumping to:
Did you have any idea that
the pantyhose commercial
was going to be that big?
- You know what, this is the guy over here
that handled that
situation, Mr Walsh and I-
- [Gary] Tell me about that.
- We were together in Tuscaloosa, Alabama,
New Jersey guy,
Hungarian-Irish,
here's Hungarian-Pennsylvanian, you know-
- East Coast, yeah.
- We're in Tuscaloosa,
Alabama, that's where
our friendship started,
when Jimmy came to New York and
passed the bar exam up here,
he's an attorney, we
started working together.
And Jimmy called and says "Joe,
"I have an interesting proposal here,
"I've got a storyboard-"
- And Jimmy, real quick,
and I apologize, Joe,
at that point, were you getting
tons of different things,
and you were vetting them?
- [Jimmy] Yes.
- And this one just caught your eye?
Did they, when they pitched it to you, say
"Look, Joe's legs are banged up,"
was it very easy to see
the cleverness of it,
or did that develop later as an idea?
- [Jimmy] No, there was a
lady from Photoplay Magazine,
who went to the University of Alabama,
and she was the editor of Photoplay,
and she happened to come in the office
to talk to me about this,
talked to me about doing a thing for her,
and basically at that point,
and I asked her, I said
"Well, what do you think about this idea?"
and she said "My father is an Iowan,
"he would be devastated if Joe
Namath ever wore pantyhose."
(Jimmy talks under Gary)
- Yeah, honestly,
Joe wearing panty, what year was it?
70, what?
Do you remember?
'75?
- [Jimmy] '72, maybe.
- Okay.
That is a risky move.
- You know what, no, man, I liked it,
I saw the humor in it,
and first of all, it was a
job, and it was a good job,
and it was with a good company.
- By the way, I've seen the
commercial a billion times,
were you blown away how good
your legs actually looked,
you know, the commercial, for
anybody who's not watching,
maybe we'll edit it on the
vlog, it's a pan-up of legs,
and it's coming kind of up from the toes,
from left to right, and
it's nice-looking legs,
and then all of a sudden, it's Joe!
(crew laughs)
Were you even stunned
when you first saw it?
Like "Man, these things really work"?
- Wait a minute.
(Gary laughs)
If Beautymist can make
these legs look beautiful,
(crew laughs)
- Still got it.
- Just think
what they can do for yours.
- Real good.
(laughs)
- That's amazing.
- Beautymist by Hanes.
- Was that one take?
- No, it wasn't one take.
- [Jimmy] That wasn't the first one,
Joe did a commercial for
pantyhose before that
for a company called Alba-Waldensian,
but that was just a print ad,
nobody saw that until a year or two ago.
- I don't remember that,
by the way. (laughs)
- Let's talk about commentating,
you make that transition.
You did that for a while.
- By the way, wait a minute,
I'm gonna interrupt you,
- Please, go ahead.
- Gary, now,
you know, you play
soccer, you play football,
even sometimes basketball,
and you tape your ankles
and knees, you have to shave your legs.
- Makes sense.
- So my legs
were already shaved, you see.
- Super comfortable.
- I didn't even
have to shave my legs.
(both laugh)
They was clean, they was smooth. (laughs)
- Talk to me about
sportscasting, you enjoyed it?
Was that fun?
Or was it
a nice thing to do, where did that sit?
- I wasn't educated enough
to know that the controversy,
the critiquing needed to be harsher,
I was more of a protective player,
still being a football
locker room kind of teammate,
and I wasn't really keen on it.
- I understand.
Talk to me about, you know,
I think a lot of people,
when they think about,
back to nerding out a little bit,
a lot of people talk about Don Maynard.
I want to talk about George Sauer.
What kind of teammate was he?
Just talk to me about George.
- Well, they're both
from Texas, as you know,
and you mentioned Don Maynard first,
and I want to go back to
that Kansas City Chiefs game,
we didn't have Don in
that game, he was hurt.
We had another Texan, Bake Turner,
but they also had a quarterback
that was really good,
he was in the Hall of Fame,
and so they shut down our
game pretty good that day.
George Sauer,
I have often said that Don
Maynard is in the Hall of Fame,
he was the lighting
strike, the knockout punch,
every team had to respect
his tricky speed, man.
He was wily,
he was terrific.
The guy I liked working
best with was George Sauer.
George Sauer and I were rookies together-
- Was he great at route running?
- He was wonderful at route running.
- You knew where he was gonna be.
- Yes, yes.
We would work after practice, man,
and as rookies together,
and we developed the timing,
it was just wonderful.
And some of the guys, the
veterans would talk about,
even the coaches, Don's lack
of discipline in route running.
Well, excuse me, he knew how to get open.
He might've rounded some routes
- Of course, of course.
- Off a little differently
than breaking them sharply or whatever,
he's a Hall-of-Famer,
- He sure was.
- He was a man.
George Sauer, you could
always count on George.
I mean, being there precise, man.
And he had hands that,
I don't remember him dropping anything.
In the Super Bowl, in
the championship game,
there was a play that
George caught a quick out,
got hit, and fumbled the ball.
Today they wouldn't call it a fumble,
they'd call it incomplete
pass, it was that fast,
Lenny Lyles hit him.
George was wonderful.
- Joe, what about now, fandom-wise,
how much do you watch 'Bama or the Jets,
or anybody else, for that matter?
- I watch 'Bama and I watch
the Jets weekly (laughs),
- I love it.
- And in this day and age-
- And you have since you've retired?
Or you took some time off, or how did your
fandom post-career develop?
Did you take some time
off after you retired
'cause you just needed to
in that point of your life,
or has literally from the
day you stopped playing,
Saturday and Sunday you watch?
- I did take some time away from football,
- Makes sense.
- I'm a Gemini,
(Gary laughs)
there's a side of me, really,
- I get it.
- And I believe
in this kind of thing, really.
I wanted out, I wanted a change of pace,
- Makes a ton of sense.
- I wanna experiment,
I wanted to learn from
these other opportunities
that I did have.
- Acting, that was
- Yes, exactly.
- A big focus of yours.
- I went and
took some lessons, some
acting, I studied acting,
I studied voice, and I
did some other things
with theater, as well as motion pictures,
but never had the real passion to do it.
They were nice jobs, they were good jobs,
but there's a side of this Gemini
that I need downtime.
It's for your health, you know,
I won't
work that way,
- I get it.
- Spending hours,
and then life evolved
into having a family,
and I enjoy spending time with the family
and also that was cool.
Leaving football, we've
talked about coaching,
those coaches work so hard.
- So hard.
- You gotta have
the passion to do it.
The passion, what you're
doing, how you go,
- 100 percent.
- You got that passion, man,
you know, that's right.
So when I got out of football,
I wanted a break, I wanted to get away,
and Jimmy continued to
guide me in directions
that we kept growing.
- And then you kind of got the bug back
a little bit again to start just watching
on Saturdays and Sundays?
- No, you know what, NFL
Ticket came into play.
You could watch your pro team,
every game, every play, man.
- You were in Florida at the time,
I'm trying to remember.
- I was in Florida at the time, I think-
- So you were able to
start watching again.
- We started out with
Classic Sports Network
was a board that I was on
with Ernie Banks and Will
Chamberlain and Larry Bird.
- Brian Bedol.
- Greenberg,
Steven Greenberg and Brian Bedol,
started that, Brian, god bless him.
- Great dude, spoke to him last week.
- And Classic Sports
Network was wonderful-
- It was wonderful, you know what?
Classic Sports Network was wonderful.
It allowed a generation, my generation,
to really get a sense of
some of the icons of sports.
I mean, it was a really
thoughtful product.
I really enjoyed it,
I couldn't agree more, nostalgia plays.
Nostalgia plays.
- Of all sports, you
know, not just football.
- So as a Jets fan,
what has been the most heartbreaking loss
for you as a fan?
Not as a player.
- Not my heart breaking.
I don't get heartbroken
- You stay even-keeled?
- Over sports, you know?
- Well, there are more important things-
- I met you very briefly,
'cause we were both walking on the field
for the Pittsburgh game,
the Doug Bryan game when
he missed two field goals
within a minute, that was a heartbreaker.
But I weirdly, if you
remember, Alex, I wasn't upset.
There's this secret, Joe,
my ambition in life is
to buy the New York Jets.
That is 100 percent
what I spend my time on,
and there is a secret part of me
that wonders if I actually
wanna be the person
that brings back the championship,
so I'm a huge fan, I watch every play,
I watch every game, three years ago,
my brother and I went to
all 16 games on the road,
it's a big passion of mine,
but there was something
weird after the Steelers game
where I wasn't as upset
as the rest of the crew,
and we drove back from Pittsburgh,
and that was the first time I said
"Do I actually want this
team to win a Super Bowl,
"or do I wanna buy this
team and win a Super Bowl?"
(Joe laughs)
Like that was the first time
I actually asked it.
- Well, how do you feel now?
- So you don't get crushed.
- Do you still actually-
- Listen, I will say this.
You know, outside of Pennington's
first 18,
before he got hurt, that first season
when he had that incredible run,
and as much as I was excited about Favre,
but I knew it was later in his career,
and that Favre team, late in
that season before he got hurt,
was probably, when they beat the Titans,
who were undefeated at
the time in week 11,
that was maybe one of
the few times I was like
"Maybe this is the team",
but this Darnold kid, and
I've gotten to know him
because my brother and I
started this sports agency,
we recruited him.
We were in his living room in California,
trying to convince him
to go with our agency.
He didn't go with us, but
we struck such a friendship,
and the last thing I said to his mother
when we were pitching him, I said
"Mrs. Darnold, if I had the option,
"if God was listening to me right now,
"and your son would sign with us
"and go number one overall to Cleveland,
"or not go with us and
go three to the Jets,
"I would pick not go with
us and three to the Jets."
- Oh man. (laughs)
- So I'm extremely,
this is no question, it's
a quarterback league,
and I do think it takes this
and this
and all these intangibles,
I think one of the things that's,
oftentimes when I get
into a nerdy discussion
about your career,
you already bought up a
couple times here today
which is why I'm smiling inside,
the great, great-
not misunderstanding,
the number one thing I think
you're most underrated for
was what you did inside the
locker room and your teammates,
when who you were in the outside world.
Without having the ability
to have the humility,
and to understand the
weight you were carrying
in the outside world,
inside the locker room,
that is absolutely your legacy
as a leader, in my opinion.
That's why you are who you are.
I think Sam has that.
Not that he has the same
level of macro-fame,
but if you do not know
how to work a locker
room as a quarterback,
and what you have to do off the field,
I mean, this kid's studying film 24/7.
I think we have a shot with this one.
- You know, I agree of course, Gary,
I watched him in college too at SC,
and he looked like he had the
physical tools and all that,
but during the coarse
of the season last year,
hearing his coaches,
especially his teammates-
- Josh McCown.
- Talk about him,
and how they talked about him,
that left a better
impression, even, you know?
- I agree.
- And getting to meet him,
and just visiting briefly
a few times with him,
really respect him.
I like his size, he's bigger than I
thought he was,
and I can't complain.
But you know, it's a team game.
- [Both] It is a team game.
- Speaking of team game,
who's the most underrated
teammate you ever played with?
Tight end?
Guard?
Somebody, obviously, there's
the names that we all know,
but a little bit left field.
Anybody stand out as
"Wow, I wish more people realized",
because what's amazing about sports,
and it's the same as running a company,
it's subtle intangibles
that are very hard to see.
You know, whether it's picking
somebody up on the bench,
whether its reinforcing something,
whether it's keeping somebody in line
who was starting to be a cancer,
is there anybody who stands out
that even the hardest-core
Jet fans may not know?
- I don't know about the
hardest-core Jet fans
may not know, because there's
one guy on our offensive line
who took a beating every week,
our center, John Schmidt.
I mean, this was at a time that,
it wasn't head slapping, forget about it,
it wasn't head slapping, man,
these cats were gonna hit
you right in the head.
- I was watching Mean Joe
Green's, this weekend,
NFL Life, with my son Xander,
did I introduce you two?
I'm trying to educate him on the game,
looking at those highlights,
it's crazy what they were doing!
- Unbelievable.
- It was crazy!
- And then the linemen had to block
with their hands in here,
they couldn't even reach out-
- They were just
- Keep cats away from them.
- Taking a beating.
- The offensive linemen,
and to this day, your games
mostly are won in the pits,
- 100 percent,
- You know,
- The trenches.
- You gotta have
the guys up front on both sides
- Facebook, YouTube,
- Of the ball.
- I apologize, Joe, put
in your phone numbers,
I'm gonna take a couple
calls and wrap it up.
So, (exhales)
what's really interesting about,
how much did you love playing in Shea?
Because Shea's got this aura,
I didn't get to go to any games there,
'cause they'd moved the
giant stadium at that point,
there was something about it.
- Well yeah, it was in
New York, for one thing.
- (laughs) Yes.
- I mean, I'm not
- I get it, I get it.
- Putting Jersey down at all,
- It was also
- 'Cause those fans
- A different time!
- Were supporters,
but this was our team out here in Queens,
you know, right there on the island there,
and also we got the
practice later in September,
because the Mets were there
and we shared it with Mets,
so we got to know Tom and the guys-
- Seaver.
- Whatever, yeah,
But also we got to
practice at Rikers Island!
(Gary laughs)
Rikers Island, as you know,
is a prison!
- Yep!
(crew laughs)
- And that's the most memorable
place I remember practicing!
- Joe, tell me about being
in New York during that time.
You guys win, the Mets
win, which was improbable,
the Knicks win a year later,
did you have a relation
with Walt Clyde Frazier?
- Oh, a nice relationship-
- Did you guys hang?
- We didn't hang, no-
- Okay, 'cause the two of you,
- He was working-
- The two of you are legendary men
off the field in New York City,
and I secretly have always,
I'm so glad I just got to ask you that,
'cause if you'd left and I didn't ask,
I would've been upset.
I was like "Ooh man, I
wonder if the two of them
"ever hit the town together."
That must've been insanity.
So you had respect for each
other, but you didn't hang.
- Oh, I was pulling for
him, well it's those eyes,
cold eyes, even, but I tell you what-
- Did you go to any of
those championships?
- Knicks games, I don't know,
I was out of town during that time,
but I tell you what,
Roger Bert-
- I was just gonna ask you,
- Was the man that swears
he was at the suave,
the suede, and he was the coolest cat.
- Did you go to Ranger games?
- No-
- Did you go to any games?
Did you go to Met games?
Did you do that,
- I tell you what-
- Or did you just kind of
stay in your own lane?
- When the season was over,
I usually
left town.
First of all, if you're in New York
186 days a year, you are a resident,
- I love it!
- And not that I kept up with,
not that I kept up with it much, but-
- The taxes are much better outside of it.
- And having played-
- That's amazing, I love that.
So you were that thoughtful about it back,
like you were real purposeful,
that makes sense, I get it.
- I only learned as I went
along, I didn't know that-
- You were like "yes, sir".
- But I knew I loved Florida,
because of being there as
a sophomore in college,
play a Bowl game against Oklahoma,
playing Texas, okay-
- The Super Bowl.
- Look at this place,
- And yeah, okay, that too.
So I knew I loved Florida,
I loved the weather down there,
I got to where I needed
- So your off-season
- Blue skies instead of gray.
- Was Florida, 'Bama,
a little Pennsylvania or no?
- Pennsylvania, my mother
and family are still,
my mother's passed but my
family's still back there,
they're survivors, but I
became a resident of Florida
in 1970.
- Ahead of your time, Joe.
- In 1970.
- Impressive work.
(phone rings)
Who is this?
- Chase.
- Chase?
- In Connecticut.
- You got it.
- Well, I know Connecticut,
I don't know about-
- [Chase] Hello?
- Yeah!
- Hey, Chase,
it's Gary Vaynerchuk, you're
on with the legend Joe Namath.
- No way!
- You did it, Chase!
- How's it going, guys?
- It's going well, Chase,
how are you?
- [Chase] Doing well!
- You got a question?
- [Chase] Yeah, so my
question for you is this:
Joe,
is there any similarities
between
being a football quarterback
and being an entrepreneur.
- [Gary] That's an interesting question,
what do you think, Joe?
- I know more about football
than I do about being an entrepreneur
and entrepreneurialship,
but I think management is important
of whatever you're doing,
and communicating with the
person there you're working with,
yeah, there are similarities
in life in general.
- Joe, you also played in
the era where you were,
correct me here, you were calling
the plays at the line, right?
- Yeah, we had the liberty
to do that, that's right-
- [Gary] Did you take that liberty a lot?
- And they still do have the liberty-
- I know, I know.
- To do that, yeah,
depending on who your coach is.
- [Gary] Of course, of course.
- I saw Phil Simms and Bill Belichick
go at it over there on
the sides, and I knew-
- [Gary] Parcels.
- Phil Simms knew what
he was doing out there,
but you know what?
If the play doesn't work-
- [Gary] You're accountable.
- You gotta have a reason,
Coach Ewbank, when I was a rookie,
told us quarterbacks
"If I send in a play,
you run what I send in,
"unless you have a better play,
"I want to hear the reason."
You gotta have a reason
to change the play,
so I did
enjoy being able to,
and we won the championship game,
basically calling 80-plus
percent of our plays
at the line of scrimmage.
- A whole lot of running.
- Well yeah-
- You saw it?
- Offensive line and
- It was dominating.
Matt Snell, I never saw anybody
play a game like Matt Snell.
I mean, he not only ran
that ball, god knows,
20-plus times or whatever,
gained so many yards,
caught passes, but
covered on kickoffs, too!
Ran down the field on kickoffs, man!
- [Gary] That's how they did it.
- It was a different era.
- Chase, thanks for calling, brother.
- [Chase] Thanks so much, guys.
- You got it.
What did you do the day
after the Super Bowl?
- Oh...
- [Gary] Did you guys
party hard that night,
or were you kind of, what happened?
- Didn't party hard, I
had my girlfriend with me,
we were relieved and we were just-
- Did you truly, I don't even know,
at this point it's been
talked about so much,
I can understand how it can
manipulate in one's brain,
but if you can for a second try,
do you think you understood
the magnitude of that win?
- To me, I understood it
only as far as a goal,
the World Championship, that's
what it says on that ring,
(Gary laughs)
"the World Champion".
It wasn't called the
Super Bowl at the time,
and I've said this again,
if you're in little league,
make them win a championship.
On every level you go,
you wanna be the best,
and that part of the team-
- Joe, I have an interesting question.
You were already kind of known, but
did your life actually completely change
after that game, though?
Like when you were at an airport,
or at a diner, no matter
where you were in the country,
did you just completely see a big shift?
- Yeah, absolutely-
- Makes sense.
- I went out to San Francisco
- Let's do one more.
- After that game,
I was going on a USO tour to
the hospitals in the Far East,
and there was a group of people
when I got to the airport in San Francisco
holding up signs and all that,
"Broadway Joe", "Congratulations" (scats).
- So you knew.
- Yeah, it shocked me,
I mean, San Francisco.
So that was the first thing I remember
about really being
recognized for that game.
- Did you ever have a conversation
about the game with Unitas?
I know he didn't start that game,
- Johnny and I,
- He obviously came in later.
- We got to visit at many charity events
and golf outings-
- You got to know him later?
- At night,
just the two of us, sitting and drinking
a little bit afterwards, we
never discussed the game.
- Never!
- No, no, no,
- No, I get it!
- It didn't need to be said,
you know?
The score said it all,
and Johnny wasn't himself,
that's the other thing,
before that game,
in Fort Lauderdale,
their defensive tackle, Lou Michaels,
and Dan Sullivan, their offensive guard,
and Jim Hudson and I, our safety,
had dinner together.
- Get out of here!
- I knew Lou Michaels
'cause he and my brother Frank
were at Kentucky together,
- [Gary] I love it.
- And so I got to meet Lou when
they came home from college,
I was maybe 13, 14 at the time,
and so we decided to have dinner,
and we're sitting at the
bar, waiting for a table,
and Lou and I, you know, and Jim, Dan,
we have a drink or two,
and for some reason,
I guess he was a defensive lineman,
for some reason, Lou turned to me,
says "You know what, Joe?
"We gonna kick your ass this week."
(both laugh)
I said "Whoa, no, Lou,
"come on, man!
"Come on!" I said,
"And besides, what do you know about it?
"You're just a kicker!"
(both laugh)
Oh man!
- He got coming.
- This Joe,
this straight boy, he got uptight,
he started to move, and 'bout that time
a guy came over with a tuxedo,
and said "Table's ready,
guys", or whatever.
So we got along the rest
of the night all right,
but there was some chop-busting.
- Obviously Johnny didn't start the game-
- [Joe] He was hurt, that's
what I wanted to say.
- I know that.
When he came in, because
he was this legend
that I know that you looked up to,
was there a part of you saying
"Don't do it, don't come in." (laughs)
- Absolutely, absolutely.
- You're like "Shit, please"-
- I can see myself standing there
on the sideline right now.
I never asked the good
lord to help us win.
(Gary laughs)
I didn't, really,
we always prayed for heath,
and we always prayed to stay
healthy and not have injuries,
but not to help us win the game.
When Johnny came out there,
I looked up at the cluck,
and I looked up to god
and I said "Please, God,
(Gary laughs)
"let that clock run out."
(laughs) You have no idea!
But Johnny wasn't himself,
- I know that.
- Like I told Lou,
before I said "You're just a kicker",
to Lou, I said "Lou, Johnny's hurt!
"He can't throw the
ball 'cross the street.
"And besides that, what do you know?
"You're just a kicker."
- I love it.
- Great.
- We calling him?
- Curtis.
- Curtis?
- [Crew] Yep.
(phone rings)
- What if he's not home?
- Think Curtis Martin's
calling us?
(both laugh)
(phone rings)
- Then we're gonna move on.
- And that's the first guy I thought of
when you said Curtis,
- Me too.
- Curtis Martin.
- [Gary] What a gentleman, huh?
- Oh man, class act, great player.
(noise over phone)
- Curtis?
- Yes.
- It's Gary Vaynerchuk,
and you're on with the legend Joe Namath.
- [Curtis] Oh, holy crap!
(laughs)
Hey, Gary V.!
- How're you doing, Curtis?
- Hey, Joe!
- [Curtis] Good.
My question is this:
In regards to,
you know,
transitioning from professional
sports at your time
to afterwards, what do you think
the major difference is now,
- That's a good question.
- When transitioning
from a pro athlete to whatever,
- Big difference.
- 'Cause I feel like
there's a lot of issues going on
in regards to
finances.
- You know what, Curtis-
- Thank you, Curtis.
- In this day and age, there's no excuse.
"The player didn't want to listen."
They're taught, maybe not from home,
but from their high school coaches,
from their college coaches,
their mentors, they're taught
better than ever before
to prepare for the time after
your sports playing days
are over,
so if it's bad luck, or they
weren't decent listeners,
the players today are prepared better
for everything outside of football,
plus the nutrition they
have, the training they have,
because of the game's growth,
and people looking back and saying
"How can we do this better?",
there shouldn't be an excuse,
but, you now,
some guys just
don't understand.
- (stammers)
Gonna wrap up on a little more
Jets nerddom word association.
Were you following during
Kenny O'Brien's years?
- Yes, absolutely.
- What did you think
of Kenny as a player?
- I think Kenny
was glad he had Wesley Walker. (laughs)
- Sure was, and Al Toon.
- [Joe] And Kenny was an ace.
He was a heck of a passer-
- His offensive line
situation was real difficult.
- Well, that's where it starts, too,
and offensively, and I've
said this many times,
the first Manning to be in
the Pro Football Hall of Fame
wouldn't be Peyton and it may
not be Eli if he gets there,
it would be their dad, Archie!
Archie never had a team to play with.
- 100 percent.
- He played with
the New Orleans Aint's.
Not the Saints, they used to
put bags over their heads,
- They were terrible.
- The fans did.
So Archie was a great quarterback,
but didn't have the team.
Dan Marino, he's in the Hall of Fame,
but didn't have a team to
win, to get over the hump,
to win a championship,
could Dan lead a team?
- Yeah, of course.
- Yeah,
give him San Francisco's
team, give him our team, yeah.
- Yeah, of course.
- So, you know,
lady luck plays a role.
- What about that defensive line,
that sack exchange, the
Kleckos, the Salaams,
the Gastineaus, what did you think about-
- And Marty Lyons, too,
- Those characters.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- Of course.
- Klecko, you're talking about a guy
that should be in the Hall of Fame,
- 100 percent.
- In my opinion.
- Made a Pro Bowl in
three different positions.
- Three different positions, you're right,
and how can that be done?
How can he not be in the Hall of Fame?
I question that, but
he's in my Hall of Fame,
and everybody, anybody that's ever played
against Joe Klecko will back that up.
- Joe, the book.
There's been a couple books with you,
the documentary was unbelievable,
I watched that opening night,
and then many times over,
is there a story out there that,
even at this point,
I always wonder about this
because I think all of us as humans,
I share a lot about my life,
I document, I do a lot of stuff,
but I always wonder about the stories
that haven't been told,
or the underrated stories.
At this point in your life,
is there any stone that
hasn't been turned?
Is there anything
like your acting career,
is there anything,
do you ever think about stuff
that you haven't talked about yet,
that you say "Will I
ever talk about that?",
'cause we all go
and hold a couple things
that we never share,
but are there things that you've
been thinking about sharing
that maybe you haven't shared in the past?
- No.
(everyone laughs)
No, you know what?
I have shared a lot-
- You have, a ton.
- And I have to duck things,
starting at home, stuff starts at home,
and you take the responsibility
for your acts and all,
and you try to make improvements on it,
but some things, you know,
are just not right being said,
what's it gonna do?
- I get it.
- Is it gonna harm somebody?
Is it gonna hurt somebody
here or whatever?
Is it gonna be positive?
This book,
a really important part of it
is reaching out, trying to help,
underdogs that feel
like they're underdogs,
you know,
I keep saying if you have a passion,
go for it, try it, don't
let anybody tell you
you cannot do something.
If you have a problem with substance,
whether it be drinking, drugs, whatever,
reach out for help.
When I was married,
my former wife asked me
to quit drinking in 1986,
and I stopped for
13-and-a-half years, all right?
Then I found a reason
to go back and drink.
I drank for a few more years,
and then the Suzy Kolber
incident changed my life.
She helped, I called her the next day
when I found out what I had
done that night, I called her,
in fact Jimmy called
me and told me about it
the next day, I didn't know.
- I understand.
- So I called her,
and I apologized to her,
and she was so supportive.
She
inspired me more than
I was inspired at the time,
but I knew I let a lot of people
down, including my family,
friends, you know, I needed help.
I needed help, so I went and got help.
I went to a facility, I got help,
I got an education, I liked to call it.
I wanted to understand
why this was happening,
- You were listening.
- In retrospect,
you know, it just became a way of life-
- [Gary] I understand.
- I got an education at
a professional facility,
then I started going to A.A.
and still run across people
and still do see people come over to me
and they kind of whisper:
"Joe, I'm a friend of Bill's."
Well, you don't have to whisper!
(both laugh)
So am I, you know what I mean!
Yeah.
- We grew up in an era where
there was a stigma around that,
and anytime we as a culture
can eliminate stigma,
whether it's alcoholism,
right now I think the stigma
of the next half-decade,
next two, three decades,
hopefully is mental health issues,
that we can start eliminating this stigma
to allow people to feel comfortable,
because other people's judgment
dictates a lot of our behavior.
- Yes, yes, and addiction,
if it can be addiction to
the good lord and love, okay,
but many of the times we talk addiction,
it's negative, you know?
- That's right, that's right.
- And, so,
if you get caught in
that kind of a thought,
if you think you've got a problem,
you probably do, and
you need to reach out,
'cause there are people
that want to help you.
- Joe, it's been an honor to have you.
- [Joe] Thank you, Gary.
- One of the fun things on this show
is the guest gets to ask
the question of the day.
So I'm gonna give you a
few seconds here to think.
You've got thousands, tens of thousands,
hundreds of thousands over the next month
that are gonna watch this.
What question do you
want to ask the masses?
What do you want them to think
about, what kind of question?
- Wow.
- Are you curious about,
- The big issue right now,
- Please, please.
- I've been wrestling with
is trying to understand
this abortion issue.
- [Gary] Interesting.
- And, you know,
I believe in God,
I believe in religion,
I also believe in the right for a lady
at a time to have a choice
on what's going on.
How're we gonna get that straightened out?
- [Gary] Starting in Alabama,
too, interesting place.
- How're we gonna get
this straightened out?
- It's a powerful question, Joe.
Thanks for being on the show.
- [Joe] All right, thank you, Gary.
- You got it.
You keep asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.
On this episode, my favorite human being
in the world stops by.
(slaps leg)
(crew claps)
- [Joe] Aw man.
- [Gary] That was fun.
(crew chatters)